so we have this from CNN factchecking
the V ramaswami CNN Town Hall where they
say a false claim that police rolled out
the red carpet on January 6 they go on
to say that you said it was an inside
job they say facts first ramaswami claim
that the riters were invited into the
capital is false about 140 police
officers were assaulted while trying to
stop the mob from breaching the capital
etc etc this is a trick that many in
media do where they will take a a true
statement a fact then try to apply it to
a totally different set of facts is it
true that police officers were injured
yes it is is it also true that police
opened the doors and fanned people in
yes it is here's a story from cnn.com
that I will useed to debunk CNN.com man
who said January 6 was magical acquitted
in US capital Riot case where they say a
federal judge on Wednesday found Matthew
Martin not guilty of four Federal
misdemeanors related to trespassing
Martin who worked for a government
contractor before his arrest following
the riot successfully argued that a US
capital police officer waved him into
the building at least one video played
during the trial appeared to show an
office moving his arm in a waving motion
yeah CNN really doesn't want to admit it
but let's break down the facts here a
judge determined a police officer made a
waving motion thus a man who entered the
building felt he was invited and thus
there were no criminal charges to be had
the case was dismissed if the police
officer assisted that man would that not
be an inside job according to Oxford
here's an article from CNN Joe Scarboro
lambasted Capital police you opened the
effing doors for them going on to say
that they politely opened the doors for
terrorists who had scrw and door murder
the media if the police politely opened
the doors providing assistance to these
people to come in would that not be an
inside job and how about this one from
the New York Post January 6 footage
shows Capital cops escorting qan Shaman
to senate floor so I I have to just
simply say when we say something like it
was an inside job or it appears to be
they'll immediately respond by saying
what's your proof that the Biden
Administration did it well I never said
that I said it was inside job the
capital police were taking selfies with
people in some instances open the doors
and let people in I'm glad to have
called out these uh news organizations
first and foremost NBC news of course
the vras Swami promotes January 6
conspiracy theory by suggesting it was
an inside job I think according to CNN's
own reporting as well as the Oxford
definition we've here definitively
stated and proven it was an inside job
my question is if the people inside are
under duress and they let the the people
outside in because they're afraid for
their lives are is it still technically
an inside job or was it provoked by the
crowd's you know fear essence of fear
it's a bit I I kind of lie with you that
I think it is still technically you know
neutrally and insight you're also
assuming that that was the case right I
mean I think that's even under that most
charitable
interpretation those aren't necessarily
the same people you're talking about
thousands of people so some people had
some violent Behavior outside different
people who show up at a door are allowed
in in a friendly manner from the
standpoint of the person who is allowed
in it doesn't matter what Circumstance
the police officer was under the
question is what do they believe the
government is telling them so from the
standpoint of that defendant I'm a guy
who walks up to the house of the people
wants to walk in take my iPhone around
you see many of those people okay
probably the first time in the capital
building and they were allowed in by a
federal police officer that of the
capital police now I find weeks or
months or a year and a half later I'm
part of the largest Manhunt in modern
American history to be put into prison
in many cases
charged held without even being charged
so I think at the level of the
individual this is what it comes down to
it's not about find what circumstance
was or wasn't understandable for the
government for somebody who's going to
be locked up we better darn well apply
the highest standard of a burden of
proof to say that's what we're going to
apply before you lock you up and so the
Capitol Police initially were sitting on
a lot of that footage they said it sat
with Congress so many of those
defendants were charged without getting
access to that video footage and again
the justification they made was you know
usually a prosecutor has to turn over
exculpatory evidence to a defendant but
here they didn't do it because they said
Congress technically has the tapes and
that's not the prosecutors of the
doj again from the standpoint of an
individual defendant it doesn't matter
it's the government that's coming after
you to put you in prison and if the
government's going to come after you to
put you in prison couple basic things
have to be true that government did not
actually cause you or incite you to
commit the crime and we're just talking
about the capital police dimension of
this let alone the FBI Dimension and the
other thing that has to be true is you
have a chance to defend yourself with
full exculpatory evidence including the
video footage of the circumstances of
you being allowed into that very
building you were allegedly trespassing
in if neither of those things were the
case then I think that that's not a
crime and anybody who has been convicted
or pressured into a false plea deal
under those circumstances will on my
watch get a pardon on day one because
that's the right thing to do to stand
for the rule of law in this country
would you retry them with the New
Evidence I think that it would depend on
the circumstances but when you think
about somebody who was first of all
peacefully protesting that day and
allowed in in those circumstances
there's something bigger going on here
in that same year we've applied a
totally different standard of the rule
of law to Violent riots I'm not going to
call them mostly peaceful protests it's
a translation if you're decoding the
media lingo on this one mostly peaceful
protest in the year 2020 FR antifa BLM
refers to Violent riots against the
backdrop of a year where there were all
kinds of peaceful to Violent riots
across this country and so against that
backdrop I believe especially what these
people have been put through already
this is years of hell that we've put
citizens of this country through anybody
who was peaceful and did not physically
assault somebody that day will get a day
one pardon from me and then I'm going to
go down the list even of the people who
allegedly right I don't believe anymore
the government they just said you're
violent as an allegation now let's get
to the facts and go down the list
anybody else who had their
constitutional rights denied during that
process will also in addition get a
pardon I can't commit to that on day one
but on day one I commit to start the
process of going Case by case and it's
not even about those defendants
individually though that matters of
course to me it's about the future of
this country because if we put ourselves
in a position where they can go after
political opponents for this reason they
can go after political opponents for any
reason you got Julian Assange rotting in
a foreign prison while the person who
leaked to Julian Assange is a Woman by
the name of Chelsea Manning who
effectively got her sentence commuted by
President Obama because she's
transgender I actually have increasingly
concluded she's probably not even
transgender she's probably just smart
knowing that that's how how you have to
identify to be a member of a politically
favorable class and so the two standards
of the rule of law are really what irk
me the most and so this isn't just for
the people who are there on January 6th
it's for the rest of us in this country
as well and so I don't think retrial for
most of those cases is the right answer
if you're a peaceful protester on
January 6 you truly peaceful and you're
convicted or forced to plead or coerced
to plead under false pretenses you will
get a pardon on day one when I'm in
office I want to bring up real quick
just uh uh to highlight again what CNN
said in their article factchecking you
when they said about 140 police officers
were assaulted while trying to stop the
mob from breaching the
capital it's it's it's not shocking that
almost every single news story that we
hear about January 6 involves those who
are acting
violently but I think perhaps one thing
that we can do better especially uh you
know we've got scanner.com sr.com we we
have a news team is focus on those who
were peaceful nonviolent and shut up
after the fact I met a a a woman at a
restaurant and this is in the Maryland
area she went down to DC with her
husband they said this is a story she
told me she showed up an hour and a half
or so after the riding had already
concluded and people were actually
leaving she walks up to the capital
building with open sidewalks there's
people standing on the grass talking
there's people walking around the doors
are wide open her and her husband walk
up see people and the police standing
there walk on walk around she for a few
minutes asked what what was going on
they said nothing much and said Okay and
she left she was sentenced to 18 months
in jail they the court did not care that
she was nonviolent that she was just a
tourist who went to see Donald Trump
speak was unaware of any barricades I
think the issue is especially for the
corporate press those stories aren't
newsworthy for them they're not going to
get clicks if you take a look at how CNN
reported the acquit of Matthew Martin
they still just don't want to admit that
a police officer waved a man into the
building and a judge agreed he was
welcomed in they still try and make it
seem like it's all a misunderstanding
and the cop wasn't waving him in yeah
and and you know what the corporate
press piece is interesting of this
because some of the people who are now
they're now going after there were
members of the press that day in the
field covering it as members of the
press but if they're part of the
corporate press somehow that was immune
from investigation you have independent
journalists who are actually documenting
what was happening are the ones that the
Justice Department's now going after got
the likes of Owen Shroyer who was
actually yelling as best I know it
didn't even go in the capital was on a
megaphone yelling 1776 I didn't think
that was a crime in this country but
apparently that was by definition they
and he ended up spending time actually
unfortunately under prosecution and
under conviction so I think it's a
violation of the rule of law I also
think you haven't even gotten to the to
the spicy stuff but first of all I want
to say one thing I'm glad that CNN you
know at least took the approach they did
otherwise we wouldn't be here doing this
actually probably you know CNN I did a
town hall here in Iowa about about maybe
a month and a half ago where we started
to talk to the this woman uh Abby
Phillips who was moderating the town
hall they literally cut it off 5 minutes
early like L was supposed to be there
was a fulltime there's a full run of
show by the time I start talking about
January 6 and there's only a few third
rails that you really can't touch but
for whatever reason this is one of them
they end the whole thing five minutes
early Trot out a bunch of different
experts explaining to Their audience why
everything they just heard was
misinformation and needed to be debunked
as dangerous for the future and then
that's when they start calling us and
and you know they actually uh on YouTube
funny thing is they threatened us with
the cease and desist for putting up that
town hall while Nikki Haley still sat up
there for 6 months I think part of it is
Tim it's not just that it's less spicy
for Less clicks I think there's
something deeper and more ideological
definitely going on here that they
believe it is their responsibility to
make sure the public does not hear what
in this case here are the facts of what
happened but even in other cases
viewpoints that are alternative to their
own I do think that's an important part
of what's going on at the highest levels
of these organizations well this is the
thing we don't know a lot of the facts
how many FBI agents played a role in
what happened how many undercover police
officers or other federal agencies
participated in this event why did it
take so long to respond what just
happened to Ray EPs and how was he able
to get that kind of deal when there's so
many people rotting away in solitary
confinement right now and you don't even
have to go as far as to say it was an
inside job or it wasn't an inside job
the burden of proof is on the government
the people have questions we should
demand answers and I think we need a
full investigation not just of that
event but the entire FBI from from its
Inception they have been doing illegal
horrible things to the American public
lying spying destroying people's
personal lives blackmailing individuals
including MLK and more importantly when
you look at what happened specifically
in 2001 in in New York City the FBI also
played a major role in that incident
that they were never held accountable
for thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IR podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net